unsurprisingly the United Nations
continues they're outrageous calls for
things like peace and an end to famine
we've all heard the belabor that we are
the world it's a mess doesn't even have
a horn section that's why America is
making strong moves to reject the UN's
hippie-dippie nonsense look at this US
ambassador to the United Nations nikki
Haley announcing an historic reduction
in the UN's operating budget 285 million
dollars Haley's announcement follows a
vote in the United Nations General
Assembly rejecting president Trump's
decision to recognize Jerusalem as
Israel's capital at that time Haley
warned the US would be and I quote
taking names yes that's how you win at
cooperating vindictive power plays which
is also the name of Donald Trump Jr's
bespoke body spray that majority of
countries voting against Trump now have
to deal with Nikki Haley's strategic
retaliation because American diplomacy
is not about negotiation you're either
with us or against us Matthew 12:30
gainst us we slash your budget but if
you're with us you get lavished with
gifts beyond your wildest dreams
the eight countries that voted no 35
that abstained and 21 countries that did
not show up for the vote have all
received an invitation from ambassador
Haley to a January 3rd reception to
express gratitude for their friendship a
little friendship party yeah oh come on
a little friendship party I'm sure it's
gonna be a huge friendship party I'll be
cupcakes pillow fights and everyone's
gonna spill all their international
policy secrets nikki Haley has invited
the countries that had the good sense to
either back Trump or keep their trap
shut so who's who of the UN Togo
Guatemala Honduras Micronesia Nauru
Palau and that's just the beginning of
the list and also almost the end which
is just how we like it
Laura grey is here now she's been to the
UN and she understands these tactics
Laura what do you see here well just
everything they don't want me
see Nikki hailey is a master of
international relations she's doing what
I like to call mean girl diplomacy which
is keeping your friends close and making
sure your enemies don't get help from
UNICEF the final goal of course being
make those around you feel like and
they'll be you oh yes great tactic I
know Jordan that's why I called it out
right anyway step one to mean goal
diplomacy is getting rid of diplomacy
you crossed me then I crossed you out oh
you're voting against my decision to
make Jerusalem the capital cool I'm
cutting you from Dan squad and turning
away your refugees Oh classic state grab
fell by I can we don't do that anymore
okay step two borma girl gang you need
to surround yourself with lackeys but
it's important that you choose your
groupies wisely they should be pretty
enough to get into the club but
desperate enough so that stylee Strether
still raises money for them on TVs yeah
she keeps coming for my money and yes
that also lets strategy sounds flawless
right you don't want a bunch of
confident pretty friends you want a
friend you can give an eating disorder
to someone you can manipulate and wield
your power over but hi Micronesia ooh do
you really need that peanut butter shake
you don't want to become a carnies I do
you know yes at the UN Security Council
harsh but fair I get it Jordan you agree
with me okay y'all got it okay anyway
obeying the queen bee USF amazing pays
off because then you get access to the
hottest most exclusive parties from 6:00
to 8:00 p.m. no party party will stop
after two hours South Sudan put the
conference right yeah suck at UK Germany
no free coffee and bagels for you that's
right mean girl diplomacy is American
diplomacy me first you suck
if you veto us then you can't sit with
us and that's exactly the message I
personally took to the UN you're welcome
this is the UN now who you befriend that
the UN is crucial because you got
everybody here you got your gross
socialist you got your rich friend amis
you got your bottom feeder fake news
don't bother talking to them and most
importantly you have super cool super
powers like the u.s. everybody wants to
be with the cool kids but not everybody
can so I was looking in the first room
for America but apparently the UN they
go by the United States which puts us
way in the back okay that's crazy
because everyone already knows we are
supposed to be first we can no longer be
taken advantage of or enter into a
one-sided deal where the United States
gets nothing in return I will always put
America first I had to see if these
people are getting how the whole America
first international diplomacy thing is
supposed to go let me ask you what you
think of the doctrine of America first
let me go first I think it's great
this world would wouldn't be very a very
nice place if you are the only one on
the globe
really yeah really yeah really
well sorry god I go first yeah are you
gonna go first no you go first okay okay
great I think it's a great idea so now
so we thinking what I want to go first
oh these people needed an America first
makeover so I cornered suppose a big
shot Stephane dujarric the UN
spokesperson with some suggestions on
how to accessorize make the United
Nations great again oh no that's not on
there because that would imply that
great I think it's already great
millions and millions people around the
world rely on the UN for education for
food putting your country first doesn't
mean that you ignore all the other
problems around the world and doesn't
mean that it's your country alone what
welcome to the nations that's it
I'm taking matters into my own hands
America get lunch first sorry I'm first
America front row first America flag
first America first America first
America first
okay nope me first my me girl diplomacy
is working these losers know America's
first no one can stop us
not even this lame-o security guard now
you're giving me an opportunity to pick
you all and confiscate the whole
equipment whatever so I got kicked out
and they took my little American flags
and I've alienated virtually the entire
world in under an hour but I'm sure this
America first policy is gonna work great
and all the other countries will be like
totally begging to come to our next
friendship party the end
[Music]